I'm Georgia I'm a senior data scientist
in the genomic surveillance unit at the
welcome Sanger Institute the genomic
surveillance unit at Sanger is
interested in using genomics to
understand how infectious diseases
around the world are changing through
space and time so this is essentially
using data in order to improve the way
that countries can treat and handle
infectious disease
so as a data scientist working in
genomic surveillance I spent most of my
time at a computer however I'm not just
glued to a computer on my own I'm
working at a computer but
collaboratively with my other colleagues
with other partners in different
countries around the world and we all
work together to try and find out what's
going on in these genomes in these
viruses and these parasites so we can
enable countries to make more informed
decisions about the way they treat
Public Health it's so key to work
together in this space
there are multiple different types of
data science that you can do and but
particularly in the space of genomics we
care about finding those stories within
the data about what's happened in order
to then predict what could happen in the
future if you're not sure that science
is the right career for you I would
encourage you to keep an open mind
because what you think science might
look like isn't necessarily what it does
look like now or in the future I
finished off my gcses thinking I was
going to be an actress taking things
like drama PE art and philosophy I then
went to sixth form to do my a levels
changed my mind after three weeks and
transitioned to The Sciences I then went
to go and do a pre-med course because I
thought the only thing I can do with
science is medicine turns out genomics
exists and you can study that on its own
so I then did an undergraduate degree in
molecular biology and genetics brought
myself how to code and then ended up
learning on the job as a genomic data
scientist here at Sanger
my favorite part of my job has to be
problem solving with my team we all come
together to solve these really important
problems within the data related to
genomics and it's incredibly challenging
and fulfilling to do these kind of tasks
in a space that's so meaningful and
impactful
I always knew that I wanted to do
something that was contributing to
making the world a better place but I
didn't quite know what that looked like
and then
fell in love with genomics fell in love
with technology I learned that I could
combine the two together in a job and
now I get to apply data science on the
genomics of infectious diseases to
enable better treatment of disease
across the world and it's just the most
fulfilling job I could ever have dreamed
of
[Music]